voters reported their top issue was
healthcare especially among Democrats it
Wishman it was mentioned by about twice
as many voters overall as immigration
the top issue for Republicans more than
two-thirds of the voters rate the
economy as excellent or good despite
that voters are down about the direction
of the country 54% said it is seriously
off on the wrong track
42% said the country is going in the
right direction and more than
three-quarters of voters think Americans
are becoming more divided Anthony Mason
is tracking some of the other key
findings from our exit polling Anthony
good morning what we're going over some
of the key factors in the good night for
Democrats well I think first let's look
at their base I mean if we look at young
voters two-thirds voted for Democrats
that's actually an improvement of 13
points over four years ago an among
black voters nine out of ten voted blue
much like they did four years ago
two-thirds of Hispanic voters also went
Democratic and that's a 6% improvement
over the 2014 midterms and while we're
looking at 2014 Democrats in that
election lost independence they lost
white women and they lost white college
voters but four years later they've
turned around and they've won all three
of those groups so a significant change
there what about the number of women in
the number how did the women boat break
down between the Democrats as we know
went after this group and they succeeded
Democrats won about 60% of the women's
vote and that's significant because
we've seen a shift in three key
categories among female voters first
single white women voters who have voted
for a pub they voted for Republicans in
the midterms since 1994 this year
there's a narrow edge for the Democrats
married women is a second category we've
seen a change four years ago they went
54 44 Republicans this time around
mirror image reverse 54 to 44 Democrat
and finally suburban women they leaned
Republican in 2014 by about four points
this time around the Democrats take
suburban women 53 to 45% you know it's
interesting cuz you hear from many
Republicans who say when they're at home
they don't hear about Robert Miller
their constituents don't care about the
Russian investigate Oh what are you
saying from the polls well this actually
I was very curious to see what the
responsible
exit poll voters was its in fact he's
about as popular with voters as the
president is the president's approval
rating was about 44% robert muller comes
in around the same range i'm looking for
the exact number here 45% approve of the
way the president's job doing robert
Muller's approval rating 41 percent
disapproval 46 so you know the other
thing that was interesting that I saw in
the exit poll is regarding impeachment
independence particularly do not want
this new Congress to proceed on
impeachment it's it's divided party
lines in the you know on both parties
but if you look at independence very
strongly opposed to the idea there was
exit polling about gun control there was
and this is a very simple question do
you support or oppose stricter gun
control measures 59 percent are in favor
of stricter gun is not as taboo of an
issue anymore the NRA their funding
dropped significantly nearly 70 percent
in this race yeah Bloomberg's group
every town put in about what thirty
thirty million dollars and some of these
races Anthony it's always good thank you